well I think if you know fashion has
gotten to a point where it's sort of
like mini Hollywood you know it's it's
it's actress light it's it's melodrama
small it's you know it's a sitcom it's
not the full-length feature movie it's
fashion provides a certain drama it's
got the ego it's got the beauty it's got
the glamour that Hollywood has and
because it's not hot you know we can't
get in behind Meryl Streep's dressing
room we can't get backstage at the
filming of that we can't see when camera
who was just on charlize theron just did
a nude scene and they did it at night in
North four o'clock in the morning
because they didn't want anyone to know
and only the director in Charlie's new
and da da da da we can't get behind the
scenes on that you can't do that the the
celebs won't let you do that Hollywood
won't allow it so you know fashion sort
of Hollywood light on some level and you
can get into a bit of the drama and the
glamour and the beauty that Hollywood
provides and this also you know a lot of
eco so you get it you get a little bit
of the a little bit of the storyline as
well
they've got to look great nuts their
image and similarly you know John
Galliano made it out of the you know the
slight obscurity when you know his
dresses were worn by you know actresses
on the catwalk on the red carpet I mean
so you know it's a great symbiotic
relationship actresses need to look
glamorous they need to be photographed
and similarly designers want to keep
their street cred with the general
public who's watching the Oscars who's
watching all these celebs reading all
the weeklies looking at all of the
online sites to see what they're wearing
when they go out when they go to award
ceremonies so you know the the the
Hollywood and fashion has gotten into
bed together and it's working nicely
actually for both of them
I'm always riveted by Madonna you know
she continues to morph even at age 50 51
she was backstage at Marc Jacobs II and
just you know slightly speechless
because I think she's got great style
and if not she's got unbelievable balls
to have the style that she wants to have
when she wants to have it so I think
she's someone that I've always found to
be interesting I think occasionally
Katie Holmes has had great personal
style and it's kind of gracious in the
way she gets dressed uma Thurman was a
model I love her style all the time she
looks just great and close you know
beyonce is sexy and beautiful and round
and I love the way she looks two very
very different
well I think of a generation the blogs
are I'd like to consider ours the cut
which is you know going through the roof
and its record-breaking numbers during
new york fashion week last week that
people are coming more to the blogs and
good smart ones that have a point of
view that tells them the news that
synthesize it also have a bit of a you
know cutting edge shall we say not to to
use the part of cut i think that's a
generational change that that really is
happening I don't think the celebrities
are in general you know I think the
olsens have great style and that's an
exception to the rule and they're also
doing a great line of clothing kind of
cool classics called the row but in
general no I think it comes from the
designers they're the ones that set the
trends they're the ones that create the
desire create the passion create the
whole aura around what you want to get
or where or see in any given season and
fashion traditionally goes from you know
yin to yang you know last fall this fall
it was about 80 s and leather and tight
and sequins and shoulders and belts or
40s a more conservative version of that
same silhouette and for spring so far
it's very romantic it's quite loose
norma's amount of texture to fabrics and
ruffles or pearls or ruching or bright
strong color things that are very
eye-popping so again you're seeing the
antithesis of what came before fashion
designers tend to be tired of what
they've just seen for six months and
they want something completely different
and fresh so if you if you if you see a
season of black you can bet that the
next season is going to be wide if you
see a season where it's short and tight
you can sort of put your money on it
might be long and lives or looser and
and slightly more poetic in its point of
view
I i think the designer today that really
designs for women that's leading the
pack on that with that in mind is Alber
Elbaz for lava I think his ability to
design this Technic his technique is his
literal ability to design a dress and
know how to technically do that is got
many peers I think albere really
understands a woman I think he
understands not only her body but her
psyche how she wants to be alluring how
she wants to feel I think he's really
entered into that space and I therefore
I think he designs with that in mind
along with an unbelievable technical
ability to make perfectly beautiful
clothing seem effortless and have a
great ease and sensuality that's very
very very accomplished and very
difficult to come by so i would have to
give my stars to the man with the most
style or ability to create that style
ultimately a woman's got to have that
style because she's putting on something
that somebody made and i think i think
Alber Elbaz would be my vote for today